auf der nächsten wochen und monate seien
steuererhöhungen neue vorschriften neue
bürokratie wer genau das falsche in
dieser phase und das werden wir auch
herausstellen es geht um die
entlastungen der mitte und das ist das
was uns wieder zu wirtschaftlicher
stärke und zu neuen arbeitsplätzen
zurückbringt in der klimapolitik setzen
wir auf
innovation auf marktwirtschaftliche
mechanismen die aus unserer sicht
erfolgsversprechender sind als die
verbote die wir auch gestern abend
wieder von spd und grünen gehört haben
und um das vorzubereiten haben wir einen
energie dialog seit mai in gang gesetzt
zur vorbereitung auf die
koalitionsgespräche mit der deutschen
wirtschaft mit vielen akteuren die ein
klimaneutrales deutschland wollen auch
mit unserer klima union die innerhalb
der cdu das thema klima zum schwerpunkt
gemacht hat und ich habe immer deutlich
gemacht ich will
unterschiedliche gesichter auch der cdu
zeigen die für bestimmte themen stehen
wir haben auf allen politikfeldern
starke köpfe das ist vielleicht auch
einer unserer ganz großen vorteile
gegenüber der spd die alle köpfe
versteckt im moment wir wollen sie
zeigen und zum team der
führungsmannschaft
gehören in dem feld klima und
energiepolitik die drei die heute hier
stehen an die jungen ihnen schon bekannt
aus bisherigen
papieren beschlüssen profilierungen der
cdu bei der klimapolitik biete winter
als eine junge abgeordnete sind
kandidatinnen die die klima union mit
gegründet hat und vorangebracht hat
thomas heilmann aus berlin jetzt schon
im deutschen bundestag der diesen dialog
mit der wirtschaft
strukturiert hat vorangebracht hat und
zugleich mit friedrich merz zusammen
diesen ganzen prozess vorbereitet
friedrich merz war ein wichtiger akteur
in dem bindeglied zwischen klima union
und wirtschaft und hat ebenfalls dieses
papier mit vorgestellt die kernthesen
sind
energiewende als motor für den
klimaschutz und als motor für neue
arbeitsplätze
klimaneutralität
2045 ist inzwischen konsens aber wie man
dahin kommt wie man eine industrie
umgestaltet wie wir die riesenmengen an
regenerativen strom den wir jetzt
brauchen wirklich real umsetzen das ist
eine frage des könnens und weniger des
forderns und deshalb geht es in dem
papier
um eine beschleunigung des ausbaus
erneuerbarer energien
der strombedarf unseres landes wird
deutlich wachsen nach schätzung des
bundeswirtschaftsministers werden dass
terawattstunden bis 2030 sein dass eine
gigantische menge im jahr 2021 haben wir
einen netto zubau von
2200 bis
2500 megawatt wir brauchen
655 terawattstunde also eine gigantische
menge und wenn wir weiter so planen wie
bisher so genehmigen wie bisher wird das
ganze nicht funktionieren wir brauchen
im moment sechs jahre für ein windrad
unser ziel ist sechs monate das ganze zu
genehmigen und auf den weg zu bringen
wir brauchen eine einen ausgleich
zwischen
alten schutz
akzeptanz und ausbau und ausbau
funktioniert nur wenn die akzeptanz bei
den menschen da ist und wenn die die
sich für atemschutz engagieren
gleichermaßen merken auch unsere
interessen werden ernst genommen und
deshalb ist das unser ziel den markt
stärken die soziale bilanz halten und
zum ausgleich in der gesellschaft
beizutragen
wir wollen unter anderem wie die
eeg-umlage abschaffen eine
forschungsinitiative für energie
innovationen anstoßen mehr tempo beim
netzausbau
beschleunigung der verfahren
zinslose darlehen für solardächer jeder
der die absicht hat sich in seinem haus
ein solardach zu errichten soll ein
zinsloses darlehen erhalten von der kfw
und konzentration von
windkraftstandorten
details werden jetzt an die jung wiege
winter und thomas heilmann erläutern und
andy jung beginnt ja meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren armin laschet wird es
eben gesagt dass ich das letzte mal hier
war hat das präsidium die forderung
erhoben klimaneutralität muss ins gesetz
deutlich vor mitte des jahrhunderts es
ist im juni beschlossen worden
klimaneutralität bis 20 45 und damit ist
der beschleunigte klimaschutz nicht
forderung und unbedingte notwendigkeit
seien es gesetzliche pflicht das hat
unmittelbare folgen wir müssen schneller
werden und ein wichtiger beitrag ist
dass wir so schnell wie möglich 100
prozent erneuerbare energien erreichen
und dafür brauchen wir ein turbo dafür
machen wir vorschläge dazu setzen wir
auf die energie der natur wir setzen auf
marktwirtschaftliche anreize setzen auf
teilhabe für alle dass die übersetzung
von ökologisch und sozialer
marktwirtschaft für den erfolg der
energiewende und wir wollen das mit
innovationen schaffen wir wollen es mit
anreizen schaffen ich will es an einem
beispiel machen wir müssen die
potenziale der sonne energie nutzen wir
wollen das auf die dächer
solaranlagen kommen und es gibt ganz
viele menschen die am freude daran aber
diese freude wird getrübt durch
vorschriften durch bürokratie durch
steuern und abgaben und deshalb müssen
die weg und wenn die weg kommen dann
kommt es so lade obendrauf und den
steuerberater ohne die abgabenlast und
dann wird ein neuer boom für erneuerbare
energien durch deutschland gehen darauf
setzen wir dafür brauchen wir auch
schnellere verfahren dafür brauchen wir
auch klima werker wie wir das nennen
klimaschutz braucht klima werke menschen
die die anlagen aus dach bringen die die
häuser sanieren
deshalb denken wir konsequenten
klimaschutz zusammen mit der stärkung
von handwerk und mittelstand
9 auch von meiner seite winter mein name
wir haben in diesem papier sehr sehr
viele konkrete und gute vorschläge
gemacht wie wir tatsächlich die ziele
erreichen können die wir immer wieder
formulieren und ich möchte ihnen die
vier punkte noch einmal darlegen der
erste punkt ist dass wir weiter auch in
die forschung und entwicklung setzen
müssen sie alle haben sicherlich ein
handy ein iphone wenn sie sich überlegen
wie das vor zehn jahren aussahen wie es
heute aussieht dann wissen sie wie wir
mit innovationen voran kommen müssen und
das können wir auch schaffen beim
repowering beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien dass wir uns darüber gedanken
machen dass wir weiter forschen wie
können wir wasserstoff einsetzen wie
können wir vielleicht auch wasserstoff
noch besser produzieren gemeinsam mit
der offshore wind technologie wie können
wir aber auch unsere universitäten
unsere professoren stärken um auf diesem
gebiet vorreiter zu werden und zum
schluss technologien zu entwickeln die
wir dann auch exportieren können um die
ganze welt kinder neutral zu machen der
zweite punkt ist dass wir als bund
natürlich vorreiter und vorbild sein
müssen für die menschen zu hause für die
kommunen für die länder deswegen sagen
wir in diesem papier dass wir die
bundeseigenen immobilien klimaneutral
aus gestalten wollen es geht darum
photovoltaik zu installieren wärmepumpen
dass wir im modellprojekt ist auch mit
windkraft versuchen und dass wir das
auch anstreben bei denen unternehmen wo
der bund der mehrheitseigner ist der
dritte wichtige punkt ist natürlich die
offshore windenergie ich komme selber
aus bremen und bremerhaven ich weiß wie
gut der wind dort weht dort müssen wir
weiter vorankommen dass wir oft schon
mehr nutzen dass wir jetzt schon uns
überlegen wie kann eine raumordnung dort
aussehen dass wir genug platz haben für
offshore-windenergie
natürlich brauchen wir und das ist der
vierte punkt aber auch wind an land und
hier ist es wichtig dass wir die
akzeptanz schaffen dass wir die
bürgerinnen und bürger mitnehmen und
deswegen setzen wir uns vor allen dingen
dafür ein dass wir windparks
konzentrieren und auf repowering setzen
das heißt dass wir alte anlagen
austauschen und durch neue ersetzen was
dazu führt dass wir häufig eine deutlich
höhere leistung auch haben von diesen
windkrafträdern und so sind das schon
mal vier wichtige punkte dieser 15
punkte die wir umsetzen können und zum
schluss tatsächlich das zu machen was
wir jetzt brauchen wir
brauchen mehr erneuerbare energien um
ein klimaneutrales industrieland zu
werden und ich bin sehr sehr froh dass
wir das als union heute die ihnen
vorstellen kann es ist großartig und es
bringt uns ein stück näher auf dem weg
ich bin mir sicher wie kann es damit
schaffen ich bin sehr froh dass wir ihn
heute diese punkte vorstellen können
guten morgen auch von meiner seite
klimaschutz muss man richtig machen
strom kostet heute für den
endverbraucher knapp 30 cent und dort
liegt die chance denn dank vieler
innovationen ist er die herstellung von
erneuerbaren energien inzwischen auf
drei bis neun cent gesunden zwischen 33
cent liegen ein enormes potenzial und
das wollen wir heben in punkt 5 unseres
papiers heißt es deswegen alle sollen
mitverdienen denn wenn alle aussteigen
sollen was für sie der energie müssen
auch alle einsteigen können und das
wollen wir eben nicht weil wir sie
zwingen sondern wir wollen dass es sich
für alle lohnt für die
mietergemeinschaft genauso wie für das
unternehmen jeder soll sich auf die
suche machen nach erneuerbaren energien
so wie er sie dann oder sie sie bauen
will und wir wollen damit auch nicht
warten weil die vorhandenen technologien
den einstieg jetzt zu
marktwirtschaftlichen bedingungen
ermöglichen und gleichzeitig wollen wir
forschen wie schon gesagt hat damit es
noch mehr innovationen gibt gerade den
gebäudebereich und so gibt es noch
manches was wir verbessern wollen das
führt uns und auch nur diese dynamik
führt uns auf den 1,5 grad weg und keine
starts wird dann wird es auch ein
exportschlager wir werden mit verzicht
und wohlstands einschränkungen und
verboten den klimawandel vielleicht in
deutschland bekämpfen können aber
niemals international denn wir werden
keine nachahmer finden wir werden die
chinesen die inder und alle anderen
länder nicht davon überzeugen können
dass sie nur verzichten sollen sondern
wir müssen vor machen und deswegen muss
deutschland auch ein vorreiter sein dass
man damit geld verdienen kann
und wenn also der erste schritt ist dass
wir alle einsteigen können sollen weil
es sich lohnt dann ist der zweite
schritt wir müssen ist so machen dass
die leute auch einsteigen dürfen da
hatten die jungs von der menge zum thema
genehmigung gesagt natürlich nicht
wiederholen würde dann noch einen punkt
sagen vielleicht kein wunder wenn ich es
sage dabei soll die digitalisierung eine
priorität werden insgesamt muss
deutschland digitaler werden und beim
klimawandel wird es eine besondere
priorität der nächsten bundesregierung
sein deswegen wollen wir dieses digitale
echtzeit kataster haben dass alle
planungsvorhaben damit sehr viel
einfacher und ihm ist auch sehr viel
schneller ging
vielen dank dann kommen wir zu den
fragen die frau schweizer von der ard
bitte
erwähnt die unterschiede sind deutlich
geworden eine erste umfrage sieht nach
wie vor olaf scholz form wie wollen sie
den umkehrten der reichen gibt es nach
strategiewechsel jetzt noch näher ran an
den wähler mehr haustür wagram
vielleicht mehr öffentliche auftritte
und
vielleicht auch mehr den teamgedanken
geben sie da auch den kritikern den
eigenen reihen nach die gesagt haben
jetzt müssen wir das team endlich
vorstellen nein ich bin seit ich politik
mache ein teamplayer und habe immer
darauf wert gelegt in meinem kabinett
und anderswo das unterschiedliche
akteure sichtbar werden und es war immer
klar dass themen mit anderen köpfen
verbunden werden ich habe ja den
riesigen tochter einen riesigen schatz
diesen riesigen fundus dass in der cdu
solche köpfe gibt das ist ja das problem
der wettbewerber dass sie die gar nicht
haben und deshalb will ich die aufzeigen
und jetzt ist die zeit heute den auftakt
zu machen das wird sich jetzt fortsetzen
weil wir jetzt endlich über themen reden
das war der große vorteil des tri ace
105 konzentrierte minuten über politik
und über unterschiede deshalb habe ich
das auch sehr gerne gemacht freue mich
auf das nächste trial den themen sind
auch gestern nicht angesprochen worden
die mir persönlich wichtig sind das
thema digitalisierung beispielsweise
braucht ebenfalls eine antwort in den
nächsten wochen
und jetzt bin ich da ganz guter dinge
herr blank von dpa bitte sehr harter
kritiker haben ihm vorgeworfen dass sie
gestern abend manchmal so ein bisschen
verkniffen gewirkt hätten und sehr
häufig nach unten geschaut haben nicht
die zuschauer angesprochen was müssen
sie da ändern in den nächsten wochen
herr scholz sei da wesentlich kanzlerin
aufgetreten und eine frage an die runde
der klimaexperten sie fordern ja den
komplett abbau der eeg-umlage wie soll
das finanziert werden
also lassen wir doch die wähler
entscheiden was sie kanzlerin finden
also kanzlerin ist nicht wenn man die
raute nachmacht wenn man politik von
angela merkel will muss man auch in den
inhalten wegkommen von diesem völlig
starts orientierten spd wahlprogramm und
davon habe ich gestern nichts gemerkt
ich habe auch ihn nun nicht als beispiel
die nicht mehr wert sind aber dass das
nun ein feuerwerk der ideen war habe ich
nicht gespürt wir haben unsere
unterschiedlichen arten ich
kämpfe für diese themen weil es wirklich
eine richtungsentscheidung ist und ich
auch in der frage die gestern wieder
nicht beantwortet ist lässt man sich
notfalls mit der linken ein und koaliert
ich finde gar nicht so schwer er benennt
all die themen wo es nicht geht ja aber
warum sagt man da nicht ich mache es
nicht es wird keinen linken
ministers die danach im
koalitionsvertrag zu gestehen eine ganz
simple frage ohne eine antwort kannst du
dich ist das nicht die kanzlerin hätte
eine klare antwort gegeben wie sie die
kanzlerin danach gefragt hätten dann
bitte ja zur frage nach der eeg umlage
die muss weg das ist auch schon eine
klare aussage im regierungsprogramm und
die kann stück für stück abgeschmolzen
und dann ganz abgeschafft werden in der
nächsten legislaturperiode mit den
einnahmen aus der aus dem co2
emissionshandel
die schritt für schritt an wachsen dass
es durchgerechnet und es ist im übrigen
eine gute antwort auf die soziale frage
weil jeder stromkunde ist und weil die
berechnungen zeigen menschen mit
geringem einkommen geben im vergleich
mehr geld aus für strom als andere und
deshalb ist es ein wichtiger beitrag für
die akzeptanz dieses weg ist der
energiewende und so können wir es mit
diesen einer mit den einnahmen aus dem
europäischen emissionshandel schaffen
die eeg-umlage tatsächlich abzuschaffen
dann die nächste frage sarah sie wird
von focus.de bitte nicht ein zweiter
vorne
vielen dank eine frage an
laschet hält
sie haben heute ein fünf punkte plan
vorgestellt im präsidium wie sie den
wahlkampf strategisch ab jetzt anders
aufstellen möchten wie können wir uns
das vorstellen und sie sagten gerade das
wird jetzt folgen dass man auf die
verschiedenen themen verschiedene
personen selbst heißt dass wir können
jetzt jede woche damit rechnen dass wir
die jetzt heute drei experten für das
thema klima und dann nächste woche drei
experten wir das thema familie
vorgestellt bekommen oder wie kann das
vorstellen ich könnte sich das so
vorstellen dass wir unsere
themenschwerpunkte jetzt mit personen
verbinden und dazu die themeninhalte
ihnen dann auch mit den personen nahe
bringen
die laute
5 es gibt kein fünf punkte plan es ist
noch einmal deutlich gemacht worden was
bei dieser bundestagswahl jetzt unsere
themenschwerpunkte sein werden das ist
zum einen das thema entlastung der
gesellschaftlichen mitte
keine steuererhöhungen keine neuen
belastung sowohl nicht für familien als
auch nicht für familienunternehmen zum
zweit sind die digitalisierung und die
modernisierung von staat und wirtschaft
ein sehr wichtiges thema werde es
erwähnt beim trainer hat sich so eine
große rolle gespielt für das was nach
der pandemie nötig ist hat ja auch
thomas neumann thomas heilmann mit dem
neustart und die bundestagsfraktion
konkrete vorschläge gemacht was jetzt
passieren muss das wird dann noch einmal
in einen konkreten plan umgesetzt
dann brauchen wir
antworten für die innere und äußere
sicherheit
es kann nicht so weitergehen nach
afghanistan das ist eine lehre sowohl
für die äußere sicherheit für die
arbeits mechanismen in der
bundesregierung wir brauchen den
nationalen sicherheitsrat im
bundeskanzleramt die spd verweigert sich
dem aber wir haben jetzt erlebt dass
dieses hin und her schieben zwischen
ressorts nicht so effektiven
entscheidungen führt zweitens müssen wir
handlungsfähig sein dass auch europäisch
abgestimmt deshalb brauchen wir neue
europäische initiativen wie wir die
außen und sicherheitspolitik die in
verträgen schon drin steht jetzt konkret
machen dass wir im notfall auch mal in
der lage sind die flughafen von kabul
als europäische union selbst zu sichern
auch ohne die vereinigten staaten das
wird eine ganz wichtige internationale
aufgabe sein und da gibt es viele
unterpunkte in der ausrüstung der
bundeswehr die in einer wechselbeziehung
zur inneren sicherheit steht denn wir
sind 2001 nach afghanistan gegangen weil
von dort internationaler terrorismus
ausgeübt wurde infolge des elften
september
es ging nicht um systemwechsel gegenüber
den taliban soll es ging damals darum
diesen rechtsfreien raum zu beenden und
jetzt wird man sehr sorgsam beobachten
müssen ob der wieder entsteht und da
muss die internationale gemeinschaft
darauf achten dass nicht erneut gefahren
für die innere sicherheit nämlich
terrorismus entsteht so das ist ein
weiteres wichtiges thema und ja
klimaneutrales industrieland ist hier
ein wenig jetzt umsetzung wird auch eine
andere foren nach sich ziehen wir werden
das woche für woche tag für tag erleben
wie wir das auch mit personen verbinden
danke dann haben noch zeit für drei
fragen herr delfs bitte von bloomberg
noch mal zu ihrer strategie sicher sagt
mehr nicht offen wenn man eine strategie
ändert aber ich kann mich erinnern sie
haben hier vorne mal im april gesagt sie
wollten einen fröhlichen wahlkampf muss
ich sagen so richtig fröhlich wirken sie
nicht und der ganze wahlkampf eigentlich
auch nicht da frage ich mich warum
können sie nicht einfach zugeben dass
sie doch vielleicht gemerkt haben dass
sie umschalten müssen und jetzt einfach
nur eine note aggressiver sind sie sind
auch ganz klar jetzt teamorientierter
vorher ist das immer es gibt kein team
also ich finde man kann schon sehen dass
ich noch ein paar dinge geändert haben
da wollte ich einfach mal hören sind sie
wirklich sagen sie jetzt wirklich sie
haben nichts geändert und sie machen
genauso weiter wie sie ist im april sich
vorgestellt ich will ihre wahrnehmung ja
nicht widersprechen das sind ja ihre
wahrnehmungen wer mich kennt wer die
argumente für meine wahl zum
parteivorsitzenden kennt wer die
entscheidungen der kanzlerkandidatur
kennt warum wer wie entschieden hat weiß
dass man immer einen teamplayer wollte
ich hab in einer parteitagsrede gesagt
ich bin nicht der ci oder cdu wir sind
ein team und dieses team herauszustellen
mit all seinen wurzeln war von anfang an
nicht erst seit meiner kandidatur mein
politisches ziel das wird jetzt
umgesetzt stück für stück wie
angekündigt zweitens ja ich hätte mir
einen fröhlichen wahlkampf gewünscht
einen entspannten wahlkampf aber die
zeiten sind nicht entspannt wenn sie
eine flutkatastrophe haben mit 180 toten
und sie den wahlkampf unterbrechen und
menschen gegenüber stehen die das alles
erlebt haben dann muss das auch
einflüsse auf wahlkämpfern dann müssen
auch termine abgesagt werden weil das in
dem moment vorgeht und die afghanistan
lage ist nun die zweite die eine solche
dramatik hinein in diesen wahlkampf
bringen der viele menschen auch in sorge
versetzt
die anteilnahme an dem schicksal der
ortskräfte unter frauen in afghanistan
das ändert in der tat den wahlkampf aber
es ändert nicht die strategie denn die
fünf themen die ich gerade erwähnt habe
sind seit monaten meine schwerpunkte
schon bei meiner kandidatur zum
parteivorsitz ist das ist die idee
weshalb ich überhaupt bundeskanzler
werden will nämlich die erfahrung dass
nordrhein westfalen aus einem großen
industrieland
deutschlandweit jetzt in einem breiten
team umzusetzen
dann nehmen wir eine frage von tagen per
online zugestellt wurde von herrn
gathmann von spiegel herr laschet wie
frustrierend ist das für sie dass sie in
umfragen trotz ihres engagierten
auftritts im trial relativ schwach
abgeschnitten haben gar nicht am 5
millionen menschen zugeschaut um die
geht's mehr
menschen kann sich ja mal damit
beschäftigen was bei der umfrage wie
erfragt wird
ein mechanismus das werden journalisten
sicher mal nachfragen für mich sind die
menschen die sich das anschauen die
rückmeldung geben und die erkannt haben
für was wir stehen entscheidend dann
bitte die dame dort hinten
oder sei jedermann ist deutsche welle
herr lasse sie sprachen jetzt wieder die
europäischen sicherheitsinitiative in
bezug auf die kabuler flughafen mich
würde interessieren wie konkret meinen
sie es jetzt also sie fordern das europa
der so stark sein sollte damit dass ein
flughafen schützen kann was heißt das
konkret ohne die usa ist das dann unter
welcher elite sollte sagen ist das jetzt
eine idee die sie direkt auf die
aktuelle lage umsetzen oder ist das
etwas langfristiges denken sie an was
konkret
also
das ist eine langfristige perspektive an
der jesus opa erst arbeiten muss wir
haben im balkan krieg erlebt wer hat
sich eine gemeinsame außen und
sicherheitspolitik im maastricht-vertrag
und dann passierte massenvergewaltigung
vertreibungs milosevic regime auf dem
balkan und europa konnte mühevoll zu
einer gemeinsamen stimme finden aber als
man die gefunden hatte konnte man nicht
handeln und erst die usa haben dann den
balkan krieg in bosnien ende der 90er
beendet danach hat europa gesagt jetzt
brauchen wir auch eine gemeinsame
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
schlossen auf dem gipfel 99 in köln wo
man sich das vorgenommen hat und in
dessen in deren umsetzung sind wir jetzt
aber wir sind nicht so weit wie bereit
sein müssten bei beeskow und bei anderem
was sie gerade gefragt haben und deshalb
muss europa aus dieser lehre des
afghanistankriegs sich jetzt vorbereiten
mechanismen zu finden sich europäisch
abzustimmen oder außenpolitik weg zu
gehen von der einstimmigkeit und die die
bereit sind zu handeln so auszustatten
dass sie in der lage sind auch einen
dass sein beispiel der flughafen von
kabul wird sich das dauer thema science
wird an anderen orten in der welt
momente geben wo europäische
staatsbürger hilfe brauchen dass wir
militärisch dazu in der lage sind was
aktuell jetzt passiert ist die
initiative des französischen präsidenten
makro der auch im rahmen der vereinten
nationen un im uno-sicherheitsrat über
sichere schutzzonen rund um den
flughafen oder am flughafen spricht dazu
ist der bundesaußenminister derzeit in
der region um auch druck auf die taliban
zu machen damit sie denen die berechtigt
sind noch die ausreise erlauben das sind
tagesaktuelle aktivitäten die richtig
sind meine perspektive ist nur über den
tag hinaus was müssen wir in deutschland
ändern was müssen wir europäisch ändern
wenn die letzte frage von herrn doll von
der welt ja dort von der welt herr
laschet ich habe zwei fragen die eine
ist ja mit mit diesem neuen format mit
einem team mit dem thema klima begonnen
warum gerade mit dem thema klima weil
das ein blinder fleck bei der cdu ist
die man jetzt im vergleich zu grünen und
spd tilgen will und die zweite frage ich
weiß nicht ob dieses format schon sehr
sehr lange geplant war wenn nicht ist es
eine reaktion auf die nicht so guten
umfrageergebnisse und planen sie weitere
änderungen beim wahlkampf wir glauben
immer noch an umfragen also dieser
prozess ich habe es ja eben beschrieben
ist im mai gestartet worden
und er ist sachlich nötig und wenn sie
zum klimaneutralen industrieland
übergehen wollen und nicht nur in
überschriften denken wie spd und grüne
sondern es konkret machen wollen
brauchen sie expertin in der wirtschaft
die sagen wie kann es denn gehen was
sind wir bereit zu leisten wie können
wir anreize als staat setzen dass
marktwirtschaftliche mechanismen in gang
kommt das ist über monate erörtert
worden das wird heute vorgestellt und
das ist keine reaktion auf irgendjemand
anderen bei den anderen kenne ich gar
nicht diese programme also es wird eine
überschrift genannt solardach pflicht
für einfamilienhäuser ok weitere
belastung für den deren einfamilienhaus
oder eigentum erwerben will hier ist
eine viel
intelligentere an reizende
erfolgversprechende idee auf vielen
seiten erläutert und das ist halt der
unterschied der eine seit wir
verpflichten sich zu irgendwas zu einer
einzigen maßnahme wie er sagen wir geben
anreize und des riesen potenzial an
dächern zu nutzen für die energiewende
ein beispiel könnte es noch 50 andere
nennen und das ist einfach eine andere
herangehensweise
marktwirtschaftliche lösung oder verbote
gebote und schlichten
gut dann vielen dank für ihr interesse
bis demnächst dankeschön